今天的视频给大家带来6款全新的免费无线AI工具
我说的不受限制是指100%没有任何形式的限制
可能操作上有些复杂
但是真的能让你实现无线生成
一段时间以来现在的AI视频生成器已经变得越来越好
生成效果非常必真
但是唯一的问题是大多数工具都有严格的审查制度
像Gedance这样的AI视频生成器
不允许在视频中使用人脸
Vivo3不允许生成任何没有衣物遮挡的内容
我知道很多人都想要一个不仅免费
而且不受任何限制的
AI图像生成器
经过一段时间的研究
我找到了这样的工具
最后一个工具
可以免费使用Seedense 2
100%合法
而且是无线免费
它不仅可以免费使用Seedense
还可以使用GPT
Nano Banana等紧急模型
同时具备多场景功能
必真的打动场面
完美的口型同步
以及电影风格的运镜
你可以完全不受限制的
使用Seedense模型
好了
我们废话不多说
直接上干货
在讨论不受限制的
AI视频生成器之前
接来展示一个
免费无线的图像生成器
它不仅免费无审查
甚至都不需要登录就可以生成
打开浏览器输入这个地址
这就是它的网站
在这里输入提示词进行生图
注意这里的提示词一定要使用英文
中文提示词生成的结果完全不可控
提示词输入完成后
我们来设置一下生成属性
这里可以选择你的拍摄角度
我选择高角度拍摄
这里颜色我选择暖色调
这里效果我选择黄金时刻
大家注意
艺术风格这里有绘画动漫
休闲照片
电影风格
3D弧片
专业照片等等
如果你选择的电影风格
这里还会出现一个影片类型选项
有冒险
恐怖片
奇幻
科幻
西部片等等
根据你的需要选择生成数量
这里最多可以一次性生成12张图
这里我选择生成6张
设置完成之后
我们点击生成
它会自动为我们生成
多张非常漂亮的高质量图片
可以看到生成的图片效果非常必真
如果想要下载图片
只需右键单击
选择图片另存为
就可以把图片下载到本地
这个工具最强的不是画质
而是不受限制的内容生成
由于我们是在YouTube上
我无法直接展示它
我们再输入一个提示词
看看它的效果
一位女性站在豪华游情上
穿着白色的比基尼
背景为海洋
超现实高细节
照片级的真实感
我们给她设置一下属性
高角度拍摄
暖色调
黄金时刻
史诗级科幻
点击生成
如果生成过程当中出现这种情况
不用担心
你只需要点击这个Change Settings
在这里选择禁用过滤器
你可以选择禁用15分钟
一小时一天
还是永久禁用
选择之后呢
我们勾选这个
我已年满18多岁
点击保存
图片就可以正常生成了
画面非常逼真细腻
好 现在我们来展示一下
另一种风格
看看它的效果如何
一名亚洲男性在公园里奔跑
我们选择动漫效果
点击生成
这里没有任何内容过滤
或者是限制系统
好 它已经生成完成了
动漫风格的彩绘
绝对达到了专业画师的水平
这款图片生成器完全免费
没有限制
你可以生成任何你想要的内容
每次我推荐一款全新的免费工具
很多人都会同时开始使用它
很快它的使用次数就达到了上线
然后通道自动关闭
这也是很多小伙伴经常遇到的问题
明明按照视频操作来的
却发现无法免费使用
所以如果你想要持续使用免费工具进行创作
你需要一个可以快速获取免费信息的通道
第一时间获取最新的免费工具
然后在方案失效前完成你的创作
本频道每周都会分享最新最好用的免费工具
如果你还没有订阅
请点击订阅并添加小铃铛
这样你就能第一时间收到我的更新了
每期视频我都会分享多种免费工具
如果其中某一个失效了
你可以选用其他工具继续免费创作
接下来介绍的这些工具都非常好用
绝对超出你的想象
尤其是最后一个非常精彩
你可以免费使用Seeds 2来生成视频
而且是无限使用
所以请务必观看到最后
下面介绍第二个工具
这个网站的名字叫做OPPO
我们打开浏览器
输入这个地址
使用你的谷歌账号进行登录
登录成功后
你将看到这个页面
我们点击创建新项目
也许很多人已经使用过这个工具了
但是你可能根本不知道
它还能生成视频
接下来的操作非常关键
一定要认真观看
错过一个步骤
你可能就无法找到它的入口
首先我们点击这个生成按钮
右侧页面会出现一个agent选项
我们点击这个agent
将打开一个下拉菜单
在这里你可以看到
有很多工具
Nano Bonana用于图像生成
Audio LM用于文本转语音
View用于视频生成
今天我们演示视频生成功能
所以选择View
在这里添加你的提示词
我这里已经整理好了一份中英文双语提示词
如果你需要可以在评论区告诉我我会把这份文件分享给你我们复制一个提示词到这个提示框中如果你细心观察你会发现这里没有生成按钮不用担心
我来告诉你如何找到它
首先点击下方的高级设置
我们选择宽高笔
然后点击上方的预览按钮
回到开始页面
此时你可以看到
提示词已经自动填充到了左侧页面当中
在这里我们就可以生成视频了
但是在生成视频前
请务必确保这里的提示词准确无误
如果在这里你看不到任何提示词
则表示你没有正确签加提示词
需要重新填写
确认无误后
我们点击开始按钮
开始生成视频
如果你在生成过程当中
出现了这个错误
不要担心
这不是你的问题
也不是方案失效了
可能是服务端异常
也可能是网络问题
这种情况在10次操作当中
可能会出现2到3次
甚至3到5次
我们点击这个restart按钮
然后重新生成
一次不成功就多尝试几次
好 现在视频已经生成完成
我们来看一下效果
画面清晰流畅
人物动作表情真实细腻
如果你要下载这个视频
点击这里
进行下载即可
这个工具不做主要推荐
可以作为备权使用
因为它每天有固定免费额度
而且有一个非常霸道的条款
生成视频即便是失败了
它也照样扣出额度
意思就是
如果一天有10个免费额度
而你正好失败了10次
那么你当天的额度就用完了
非常霸道
所以建议作为补充工具使用
接下来我们介绍第三个工具
打开浏览器
搜索谷歌VDIS
点击这个链接进入它的官网
使用你的谷歌账号进行登录
登录成功后
你将看到这个界面
我们点击View 3.1
在这里你每天可以免费生成10个视频
如果你用多个账号可以循环使用
每个账号都可以免费生成10个视频
这里提供了两种视频生成方式
一种是文声视频
一种是图声视频
我们首先演示文声视频
在这里输入提示词
选择宽高比横屏还是竖屏
我们选择16比9
然后点击生成
它的生成速度非常快
生成一个视频大约需要30秒
好 视频已经生成完成
为了方便查看
我将视频拖到编辑区
然后点击播放按钮进行播放
可以看到效果非常不错
人物光线动作非常自然
如果你要下载这个视频
点击右上角分享按钮旁边的这个三角符号
选择下载为MP4
即可下载到本地
下面我们来演示一下它的图声视频功能
点击这里
选择图声视频
我们上传一张图片
提示词不变
我们依然使用这个提示词
直接点击生成
好 已经生成完成
为了方便查看
这个图片我也把它拖到编辑区进行查看
由于编辑区已经有了一张图片
如果你要想覆盖
把新视频拖过来即行
如果你想保留原来的视频
那么我们在这里点击加号
添加一个新的编辑区
然后把视频拖过来
我们点击播放按钮看一下它的效果
效果非常不错
音效 画质 光线 人物动作非常自然
好 这就是第三个视频工具
接下来我们介绍第四个免费工具
这个工具同样是由谷歌出品
我们在搜索框中搜索
然后打开这个链接进入它的官网
这就是它的官网页面
如果你还没有登录
需要使用你的谷歌账号进行登录
登录成功后你将看到这个界面
点击你的账号
可以看到这里有50个免费积分
谷歌每天都会赠送你50个积分
我们点击下面的新建项目
进入生成页面
点击这个模型按钮
在这里可以看到它有两个功能
一个是视频功能
一个是图像功能
生成图片不消耗积分
无论你选择哪个模型
它的积分消耗都是零
你可以在这里选择你的图片的尺寸
每次生成一到四张
视频功能这里不同的模型
价格不一样
最便宜的是这个
生成一个视频只需要七个积分
最贵的是这个模型
一个视频需要100个积分
如果你对品质要求不高
可以用最便宜的
如果想兼顾价格和质量
我们可以选择这个
好 接下来我们先演示图片功能
看看它的图片效果如何
我们选择16比9尺寸生成两张
给它一个其实词
这个工具非常强大
很多无脸博主都在使用这个工具来生成图片
然后再用这个图片去生成视频
从而制作出全自动化的A视频
图片已经生成完成
我们可以看一下
非常的自然
皮肤纹理非常必真这是它的图片生成我们再看一下它的视频生成怎么样点击视频尺寸16比9生成一个给它一个提示词这里谷歌每天送送的积分
可以生成五个视频
如果你有多个账号
可以循环登录使用
好 生成完成
我们来看一下它的效果
效果非常震撼
完全看不出是免费工具生成的
这个效果完全可以媲美主流的收费工具
而我们这里没有花费任何费用
如果你对这个视频满意
可以点击这里的下载按钮进行下载
接下来我们介绍第五个免费工具
在浏览器地址栏中输入这个地址
打开网站
使用你的谷歌账号或者是邮箱进行登录
登录成功后你将看到这个界面
我们点击这个Krita进入生成页面
在这里你可以看到
每次生成视频所需要花费的积分
这里可以看到
用户登录就会送我们300积分
因为我已经生成过图片
所以这里显示260
赠送的积分大约可以生成10到20的视频
这个额度对于大多数人来说是远远不够的
但是不用担心
稍后我会演示如何绕过收费系统
无限免费的生成视频
所以请完整观看
不要跳过任何环节
点击这个video按钮
在这里可以通过上传一张图片来实现图声视频
也可以直接输入歧视词来进行文声视频
这里我先上传一张图片
输入一段提示词
在这里呢
一定要注意
提示词写的好
生成的效果就会很惊艳
提示词写的不好
生成的质量就会大打折扣
如果你不想手写复杂的提示词
可以跟我一样这样操作
输入一段简单的提示词
然后点击这个提示词增强功能
让它来润色你的提示词
我们点击生成
好 视频已经生成完成
我们来看一下效果
可以看出生成的效果非常不错
再次强调一下
这是我们免费生成的视频
画面非常逼真
但是唯一的缺点就是生成的视频有水印
不过不用担心
视频最后我会告诉你如何处理水印
采用我的方法处理的效果非常好
下面我来揭晓如何绕过收费系统
无限免费的使用这个工具
我们退出当前账号
在这个登录页面我们选择免费注册
在这里我们不要使用自己的真实邮箱
使用临时邮箱进行注册登录
打开一个新的TableYer
输入这个地址
页面打开后
这里会自动生成一个邮箱地址
在这个邮件地址的下方
有一个收件箱用来接收验证码
现在我们复制这个邮件地址
回到我们的注册页面
粘贴这个地址
发送验证码
接着我们返回临时邮箱页面
这里就收到了一封邮件
我们点开这个邮件
复制这个验证码
粘贴过来
使用邮箱继续
在这里设置一个密码
输入完成后点击完成
这样一个新的账号
我们就注册成功了
整个过程不到10秒钟
你就拥有了一个新的前账号
这个方法不仅仅在这里可用
对于所有支持邮件登录的工具
你都可以采用这个方法实现无限免费
好 这就是第五个工具
接下来我们进入重磅工具推荐
第六个工具
Rumina
这个工具真的非常好用
你可以使用Sedence模型免费无限量的生成视频
之前跟大家分享过这个工具
很多小伙伴操作之后没有拿到免费资格
向我反馈说方案失效了
经过本人实地测试
方案并未失效
没有拿到免费资格的小伙伴
可能是操作姿势不对
如果你手上只有一个Gmail账号
一次失误就可能意味着失去了全部的免费机会
今天给大家介绍一种全新方案
不再依赖自己的真实邮箱
不用担心失败
一次尝试不成功
你可以进行多次尝试
所以请认真观看下面的操作
每一个步骤都至关重要
首先我们打开谷歌浏览器
搜索这个名称
我们点击这个链接进入它的官网
这就是它的官网页面
我们点击登录
使用你的谷歌账号或者是邮箱进行登录
登录成功后你将看到这个界面
如果你仔细观察
你会发现当前这个账号积分为零
常规操作下生成一张图片需要三个积分
而生成一个视频需要45个积分
我们当前账户积分为零
这就意味着在常规操作下
你无法使用这个工具
今天使用我的方法
你就可以像我一样免费无限量的使用它
生成图片不需要积分
生成视频
同样不需要积分
完全免费
无限使用
为了证明我没有说谎
我在这里输入一个提示词
生成一张图片
可以看到
积分为0
点击生成
好 生成完成
我们看一下图片
可以看到
我没有消耗任何积分
就生成了高质量的图片
视频也一样
我这里选择
AS视频
给它一个提示词
同样不需要积分
直接点击生成
我们等待几秒钟同样的不需要任何积分我就生成了一个高质量的视频画面非常清晰这就是由顶级模型生成的视频接下来我向你展示
如何实现免费使用它
首先
我们打开一个新的表现页
搜索Chrome Web Store
打开经用商店
我们搜索这个名称
点击进行安装
安装完成后
我们点击扩展程序
可以看到安装后的查件启动它
这里需要注意
在选择微频节点的时候
我们一定要选择非洲国家
或者是新加坡节点
我们找一个非洲国家
当显示连接成功后
你需要确保你的出口IP是正确的
否则可能导致操作无效
前面的工作全部白做
很多人没有成功
大概率就是这里出现了问题
如何确认出口IP是否正确呢
在你的浏览器当中打入这个地址
你的VPN连接的是I级接连
这里就应该显示I级的IP
以及I级的DNS
如果IP不对
说明VPN插件没有正确接管网络
重新安装并检查你本地的网络设置
如果是DNS不干净
显示有指定节点外的IP
请手动把本地DNS指向谷歌
打开你的网络设置
点击更改适配器
右键你的网络
然后选择属性
双击这个选项
在这里设置DNS服务器
设置好完成之后
再次检查
直到这里出现比较干净的DNS
以及干净的IP
表示网络正常
网络环境确定一切正常后
我们继续操作
我们回到Dreamin的页面
现在你需要用一个新账号进行登录
因为我之前已经使用谷歌账号登录过了
这一次我通过一个临时邮箱来进行登录
参考前面介绍的临时邮箱创建方法
使用临时邮箱注册登录
使用新账号登录成功后
你将看到这个界面
这里可以看到我们的积分是0
不用管它
我们不需要积分
点击这里
你会发现部分功能受限
只能生成图片和生成声音
生成视频功能不可用
不用担心
现在我们断开微频
然后刷新本页面
再次点开这里
你会发现所有的功能都已经正常了
现在你就可以无限免费的使用它了
这里我选择AA图像
本次图像生成
积分消耗为0
我们再选择视频生成
积分消耗依然为0
看到这里
说明一切都应该没有问题了
你已经拥有了完全的访问权限
现在我们来验证一下
是否能够正常的生成图片和视频
我们首先生成一张图片
给它一个提示词
点击生成
没有问题
可以正常生成图片
图片质量非常高
如果需要下载
直接点击这个download
就可以将图片下载到本地
我们再来生成一个视频
选择AI视频
给它一个提示词
可以看到积分消耗为零
我们点击生成
好 视频已经完成
我们看一下
视频质量非常高
画面清晰
人物动作光线运镜都很细腻自然
如果你要下载这个视频
点击当劳的
完成下载即可
最后呢
给大家介绍一款去水印工具
打开浏览器输入这个例子
我之所以推荐这个工具
是因为它的水印去除效果非常好
它不是一个完全免费的工具
但是我们可以通过一些手段
来绕过它的付费限制
稍后我来告诉你如何操作
首次打开网站
你可以使用你的谷歌账号进行注册登录
登录成功后
你可以看到这个界面
新用户赠送10个积分
每日签到
还可以额外赠送积分
点击这个按钮
我们先上传一段带水印的视频
它有两种模式
手动模式和自动模式
手动模式下有两个版本可以选择
一个基础版
一个专业版
每个版本下每天都有两次免费机会
当然这里我已经用完了
这两次免费机会是不消耗积分的
免费机会用完之后呢
用专业版720P这个选项是最划算的
4秒钟消耗一个积分
送送的10个积分
我们可以处理大约40秒的视频
对于大多数人来说
这个额度其实是远远不够的
你可以使用上面介绍的临时邮箱的方式
进行注册登录
一个账号的额度用完了
花费10秒钟更换另一个账号继续使用
这样你就能无限免费的使用它了
下面我们来看一看
它的水印驱除效果如何
用鼠标框选住这个水印区域
点击驱除
几秒钟之后就处理好了
效果非常好
几乎看不到痕迹
点击download
即可下载到本地
好了
以上就是今天的全部内容
本频道每周都会分享
最新最好用的免费AI工具
让你真正实现零成本内容创作
如果你喜欢这个内容
欢迎点赞订阅并添加小铃铛
我们下期见